please welcome romish ranganathan he's
one of the most popular stand-ups around
I'm hosting this [__] I think that all
comedians are wired slightly differently
and something happened to them that has
made them an outsider in some way what
is that for you we lived in a nice house
we had a nice car all the stereotypical
things that you mark success with then
it was a period of six months it was
complete 180. what was the Catalyst for
that 180 well shut up mate I'm addicted
to doing stand-up and it makes me better
at everything but I've got this inner
voice that is horrific it will say
you're not a very good dad you're not a
very good husband I had one of about six
panel shows and I was in a really bad
place and I turned up to each one of
them with the steadfast belief that I
was [__] at this what happens when it
does go horrifically
it's horrible at that silence that never
gets easier man but you learn more from
those Googles I just need to do the best
I possibly can at this gig I'm not in
control of anything that happens after
that don't think about this goal down
the line that you're trying to get to do
this thing brilliantly if you love what
you do and you do that you're on a good
part this is such a right time but
I've got an absolute stitch up are you
joking
we're having such a nice time
hello everybody thank you for tuning in
to watch this episode honestly an
incredible episode but I have to say
thank you before we begin because we've
hit a million subscribers on this
channel now and I it's almost
Unthinkable it's I can't you know I'm
speaking for our entire team here when I
say it's genuinely genuinely Unthinkable
biggest privilege of my life to get to
do this means the world that you guys
tune in every every week to listen to
these episodes so I just wanted to say
thank you thank you to all of our
subscribers roughly 65 of you that watch
this channel now subscribe to the
channel which is amazing if you haven't
yet subscribed could you please do me a
little bit of a favor
um I can't tell you how much it helps
this Channel and how much it's helped us
to pull in amazing amazing guests and to
expand everything within our operations
and how it's also going to help us
enable the the year that's to come and
all the plans we have some huge plans
which I'm going to be bringing to you
very shortly but if you can just do me
the one favor and hit that subscribe
button it will be tremendously
appreciated by myself and all of our
team here really really hope you enjoyed
this episode thank you for being here
thank you for helping us reach this huge
milestone of a million subscribers
let's get on with it
[Music]
I'm so fascinated by comedians because I
find it to be
an art form that is both genius and
terrifying um so for someone to want to
pursue that career I'm always intrigued
by like why so can you give me the
context that you think from your
earliest years
might have influenced you taking that
path if we go before you're even 10.
well I did stand up comedy when I was
eight you know for the first time where
like
I mean
the truth is I fell in to stand up by
accident but when I was a kid
I we used to go to this my mum and
Daddy's Texas video store and they'd go
you can choose something each and we'd
all watch it together or whatever
and my mom always always used to pick
like pink but she loved like inspector
closer and like Peter Sellers and all
that so she would choose all that stuff
and then I discovered Eddie Murphy I
remember like getting out uh Beverly
Hills Cop I launched Beverly Hills Cop
and I was just like this guy is like so
incredible and then I started watching
everything Golden Child Trading Places
all of that as a kid I was too young to
be watching that stuff and my mum and
dad had no idea about age rating so they
were fine with it and then I discovered
raw which was like his second special
that came out I think and
I remember watching that
and I watched I'd had watched stand up
before on TV like British stand up I'd
watched a lot of it as a kid and loved
it
there was something about watching a guy
and he just had a microphone
and he walks out in that leather suit
and not that I'd ever worn a leather
suit or whatever will but like he walks
out like it's a rock gig I mean like the
whole crowd like this massive crowd they
go nuts and they watch a show
of somebody just talking I just found it
unbelie like the low fineness of it the
sort of thing of I'm gonna say things I
think or my take on stuff and that's the
show there is no more than this Like
There's No Effects it's just literally I
am going to just stream of Consciousness
the illusion is Extreme of Consciousness
I'm just gonna like talk
and you're gonna and that's the show I
just found it incredible and so then
we went
my family took me to ponton's Holiday
Camp me and my brother for a like a week
and they had a talent competition and
all I used to do then was read joke
books like everything I read was like
3001 jokes
like joke books for kids like I just
thought that was all I would read all
the time because of that Eddie Murphy I
think so I mean I was just really into
comedy I just loved it I love the idea
of making people laugh I love the idea
of doing comedy I was just so obsessed
with it and so then I entered the talent
competition as a stand-up it was
horrendous but I won
I you know I won I beat this kid this
kid play now kazoo and there's another
kid doing a dance thing
smashed it absolutely smashed it but
like even then I really loved stat I
like love stand up but the idea that I
would do that for a career
as somebody from
like an Asian background or whatever you
know like my parents are very much like
you're gonna you know we've come over to
this country for you to
to follow a path and be successful the
idea of didn't sign up as a career was
not we just wasn't ever in the
that stereotype of um immigrant Asian
parents trying to make your doctor a
lawyer yeah was that did you witness
that firsthand from your parents as in
did they have that conversation with you
at any point or was it just kind of
there in the background as an
expectation they did they didn't
explicitly say you're going to be I mean
my dad was pretty laid back to be honest
with you my mum was a bit more
was a bit more kind of dead set on what
we were going to do but you know there
was there was
my mum and dad
my mom and dad left Sri Lanka
for my dad to finish his studies you
know it was an economic reason but also
there was trouble going on in Sri Lanka
you know like my family originally Tamil
there was lots of trouble going on with
the single ladies in the Indian
government and it's like a civil war
going on and that was affecting a lot of
my family members as well
so there's like a lot of push and pull
involved in them coming over here
but
they never sat me down and had a talk
but every single time I made a decision
or talked about what a levels I was
going to do and it's not that I was
conscious of the fact that they were
really worried about what I was going to
do you know for example not going to
University was not an option for me I
mean really I mean unless I really
decided to Rebel
but they just assumed I was going to
educate myself to whatever level and
then go off and follow this path of
being a successful whatever
um
so yeah that's kind of it was kind of I
felt it do you mean but then they never
had an explicit chat but I did feel it
when I was reading through your story
and going through the notes on your
autobiography it kind of I I really
could relate to
um your childhood in many ways because
it seemed like your childhood had very
distinct
um opposing chapters right one might say
and from came I came to the country when
I was a kid from Botswana and the first
chapter was great right but that's the
chapter I honestly can't remember yeah
because I was below the age of 10 my
siblings can remember it with great um
great detail but I can't remember that
chapter I'm told about it I'm told about
the presence and the everything kind of
being normal and then the second chapter
which I can remember vividly because I
was slightly older is when kind of chaos
ensued yeah and everything seemed to
fall apart
what was that first chapter for you like
to be honest it's very similar to what
you're talking about you know I remember
I remember being very comfortable and I
remember my dad's
you know all the stereotypical kind of
things that you that you mark success
with my dad wore a suit to work do you
mean we had a nice car
we never really wanted for anything we
lived in a nice house the people that my
fat like my family were like had a big
Social Circle they were you know all of
those like external signifiers that was
all happening
so like my kind of recollection
to be honest my recollection was being
spoiled to be honestly like I had
just loads of stuff I mean like my mum
and dad my mum and dad bought us loads
of stuff but they we'd go out to eat a
lot
you know my dad was doing well he was
doing really well which I mean and so
yeah similar to you I don't have vivid
memories of it but I do have a general
memory of like
you know if I asked for a thing for
Christmas
it was pretty sure it was pretty likely
I was going to get it I mean for the
first eight years or so
so it's really super comfortable you
know what I mean and then it literally
was I would say over the period of
six months so everything got completely
turned upside down it was like
it was just a complete 180.
what was the Catalyst for that 180
sort of unbeknownst to me my dad was
kind of
was not doing great at work he was
starting trying to do other it was sort
of messing around it was what do I mean
by messing around like he was just a bit
of a loose cannon I mean I think it got
got to his head a little bit he drank a
lot
it was a bit of a womanizer
um and that was starting to get noticed
at his work and then he started having
ideas of like
going off and doing other things he
ended up getting I think he got fired
from his job
and then he started trying to do this
kind of import export deals which at the
time we thought oh that's my dad's New
Path but as it turns out was illegal but
like he
basically we ended up getting that the
first thing I had was that uh my mum
said we're gonna have to move out of
this house this house has been
repossessed right so my mum and dad
couldn't keep up their mortgage
repayments
and then we ended up moving to this
house on this councilor stay that my dad
had got off a friend or was renting off
a friend we were there for a little bit
and then while we're at that house my
mum found out that my dad had been sort
of sleeping regularly sleeping and
started a relationship with this other
woman
and was intending on leaving us and the
like leaving us to go and start a life
with this other woman
and so that through my mum's kind of
world upside down
and then basically the the the sort of
trigger for
everything going really kind of mad was
we hadn't seen my dad for a couple of
days
and
my mum said
I'm gonna it was a mad I can't remember
how how old it was maybe like 11 or 12
or something
my mom said I'm gonna take you to This
Woman's house and I need you to go to
the door and ask where your dad is
because I've not seen him for two days
and I've not heard from him
so she took me around to this house we
went to the door I said where's my dad
and she said your dad was arrested two
days ago and it turned out that they'd
been in the middle of doing some sort of
deal or something and they're Opera they
were the target of some sort of police
investigation in Leicester the police
stormed in or stormed in and arrested
them and my dad is being held and ended
up going to prison for he was sentenced
to two years so
so then everything kind of went
it sort of went to chaos like my dad was
in prison we ended up being housed in a
bed and breakfast uh by the council
because they didn't have enough housing
so my mum my brother and I were staying
in uh in a room in this bed and
breakfast in horley
and um
my mom like had she'd not been working
but she got herself a job as a cleaner
and then
we were going to school from there do
you mean like and
yeah it was just like it just sort of
like everything completely flipped man
and so it was kind of
yeah it was just a complete 180 I mean
at the start of that 180 your dad was an
accountant right yeah
and then he'd lost his job yeah cheat on
your mom yeah
gone into sort of financial disarray
ended up in prison yeah in the in the
process of what six months or something
well the house got repossessed uh we
found out about I think that sort of
appeared from start to finish maybe 12
to 18 months I think
and at that point you were in at the
start of that you're in private school
right yeah yeah so I'd got a scholarship
so
um
I've done this I I was I was at school
and then
what I didn't realize is that my mum and
dad were struggling to pay my dad had
lost his job and was trying to make his
way in other ways and was struggling to
pay for the fees and so the first I
realized about it was like accountants
from the school were turning up to my
lessons with like an invoice going for
you yeah to pass on to my parents
because my my mum and dad were in such
arrears
and then eventually I got one day I came
home from school and dad said to me you
can't you're not going back tomorrow
like we've got to take you I think it's
like Midway through through term he said
you can't go back because he was just
getting freaked because he'd like he was
in such a race he was worried about what
would happen even if I turned up you
know just not that they were going to do
anything to me but I think it got to the
point where he just had to take me out
he couldn't see a way of paying any of
the money anymore so then like two days
later I was like enrolled at the local
school did you say bye to anybody no no
I mean I've got there was a mate of mine
that I'm still in touch with now
um who I kind of let know what was going
on or whatever but um nobody else no I
just like one day I was there one day I
wasn't when I look back on my own life I
it's taken me maybe like 30 years to
realize like the underlying shame
and so when I was looking through your
story I was trying to understand if
there was that same feeling of kind of
underlying shame
well like to give you an idea so I I
went to I started at the state school
and
I really enjoyed it and I had I had a
slightly opposite experience to you in
terms of like
when I was uh when I was at the the
private school I was one of the only
Asian kids there and I got loads of like
I got a fair bit of racism and then when
I moved to state school there were more
kids of color at that school I still got
wrapping I got into my fair share of
scrapes with races but like
that's it's a weird thing I was really
enjoying my time at school and it was
actually a respite from being at home
because like when I went home it was
just like everything's gone to [__] my
mom's really sad like and obviously I I
wanted to support her in that but School
felt normal I didn't tell anybody at
school what was going on at home right
so I'd go to school and that for all
they know like everything's like totally
chill but and to get like so my dad
went to prison
on the 26th of March my birthday's on
the 27th of March right and I went to my
mates my mates organized like a little
like get together watching films and
stuff I didn't tell them and I didn't
tell him I didn't tell them but I was
just like I don't want anybody to know
about this so I turned up to the like to
this birthday get together the day after
because I didn't want to pollute my
school experience with that do you know
what I mean so so I just didn't tell
anybody and like I had really
embarrassing experiences where when we
moved out the bed and breakfast we were
putting this flat and there's no phone
in the flat there was a pay phone
downstairs so but I didn't want my
friends to know that I it was a pay
phone so I had to like make them promise
me they were going to call me exactly
this time and then stand by the pay
phone so that nobody from any one of the
other flats was going to answer it and
you know what I mean
it's so stupid but I was just so
wanting to nobody to know what was going
on there's a cost to that there isn't
there
you know what I mean like that that kind
of living with the sense of
embarrassment almost
yeah I I guess like there's there's lots
of little things that there is a stress
at trying to live a double life you know
you know things that would normally be
okay you suddenly panic over so for
example there was a girl I liked and we
were like we were living on this cancer
that we've been putting in a house we've
been put in this house but we couldn't
afford carpet so it's just we just have
wooden like just the wooden floors in
there
you think it was fine but just no
carpets it looked it looked strange and
then we were walking around the estate
and then this girl that I like said oh
do you mind if I come in and use a
toilet I mean
[Laughter]
I didn't get a panic attack I thought
you can't
you I I remember like what do I do here
I can't say no you can't use it to like
I start thinking what can I say my mom
doesn't like girls using the toilet in
my house like what what can I possibly
say in the end I said I think I said
we're between carpets
foreign
that's actually really quick thinking
but yeah all that kind of stuff is just
it's just so stressed it's so stressful
man we you would you described yourself
as a lazy kid yeah I really was yeah
you're not now you're not a lazy person
now so I still do think I'm quite lazy I
I
I just was like all of my school reports
said romish is wasting his ability
rumish doesn't apply himself romish
doesn't
um and that was true before everything
not to the same degree but it was sort
of true
before everything kind of went
topsy-turvy but it was definitely true
afterwards you know a lot of teachers
say to me you're not applying yourself
at all
but I sort of think for a while I went
through a phase of just having given up
to be honest with it because it's sort
of gone so
to my mind my world had been turned
upside down so completely
I couldn't really see the point and I I
just sort of I just wanted to have a
nice time I wanted to enjoy myself and
that didn't that meant not working it
didn't initially it did not give me
you know when you're talking about when
you wrote down your list of targets it
sort of had the opposite effect and I
just thought I don't give a [__] anymore
I've seen my dad work really hard
you know I didn't know the full details
of what it does you know all of that
sort of stuff came out in the wash but
like at the time I think I've watched a
man work really hard and then he ended
up in prison he split with my mum I mean
they got back together it's like it was
terrible
and I actually went through a phase of
thinking I know
I went through a phase of thinking that
we were just cursed because like so many
so many things so many bad things happen
in quick succession
I actually went through a phase as a kid
of thinking that happiness is something
that will always elude me or like I will
never be comfortable you know this I'm
never
this is just what we're supposed to but
you know like my parents are Hindu they
talk about you know talk about God a lot
in our house and so Sonny's going maybe
God just doesn't like us man you know
that I genuinely had that genuine belief
that like maybe this is just how it's
supposed to be so it kind of pushed me
the other way I stopped working I
started bunking off
I just wasn't I just wasn't in the zone
at all what was your opinion of yourself
during that time
it's a great question because to be
honest with you what my opinion of
myself is now is something I really
struggle with and like I've never
thought about the origins of that but
um
the
the truth is
I think when I've come to reflect on it
after that and I remember thinking this
at the time I remember thinking
I don't know what I would have ended up
like if we'd have stayed comfortable you
know I don't know what person it would
have been if I'd have stayed comfortable
and I would I'm telling you now if that
hadn't happened to us I wouldn't be a
comedian now I wouldn't be the person I
am now like there's so many things that
defined who I am
I was defi so much of me has been
defined by that period
um
but what I would say is my opinion my
opinion of myself
was and continues to be something I
really struggle with in terms of it
being absolutely like like Rock Bottom
you know you know like you just I just
have
uh
uh I have a prick living in my head that
talks to me all the time I mean and so
and that is something that to this day
as I'm sitting with you now I have to
contend with I mean I've got like this
inner voice
that is horrific Jim it's like a
horrible horrible person that I've got
like you know this horrible voice in my
head that just like regardless of
whatever external
um evidence there is or whatever
whatever else happens I will always have
this kind of this inner belief
uh that I'm sort of a bit shitty do I
mean like or I'm not
I can't do this or I'm not good at this
or you're getting away with this or
whatever imposter syndrome I guess is a
is an oversimplified way of of
describing it but
yeah it's something I've I've sort of
had to I've not had to do with something
I've dealt with for as long as I can
remember really I got really I got
chills all over my body then and I don't
really know do you know why it is it's
because it really breaks my heart to
hear that that right and it genuinely
does like because and it also I think
people don't understand the privilege
that they have if they don't have that
in there right yeah
yeah I totally agree I mean it's it's
such a difficult thing because
because if you don't have that you don't
understand why somebody would have that
you you go what are you talking about
yeah snap out of it look at your life
and go yes for comedians 100 you sort of
go
and it's not that I'm unhappy with my
lot it's not that I want anything it's
nothing external I don't need anything
external to change I just have that you
just have that you know I've just always
mentally had that and yeah like what you
just said I totally relate to because
sometimes I've not you don't tell people
because you just sort of go they're
going to go what what you want about
like what what are you talking about but
people that get it get it I mean it's
like I do think
you know it's something that I've kind
of got involved with
as much as I possibly can
is to sort of encourage those you know
those kind of mental health
conversations and stuff I think we've
become much more open about it than we
were in the past but when I was at Uni I
went to see a therapist that like
the headlight is free therapy sessions
for students and I went along to one and
I did like a whole course whatever I
remember telling my mum about it and she
like freaked out you know because
what do you mean you're going to a
therapist like what is there something
wrong with your head you know like she's
like really like because to her mind
does that mean you're mad like I mean
like she didn't have that same it's like
her understanding of it now it's
completely you know she's completely
you know she's her attitude towards it's
very different but yeah it's just
something you have to contend with and
and
like at the moment as I'm talking to you
now
I've got coping mechanisms and I'm sort
of on top of it but I'm I'm always sort
of this clutch you know if I get if I it
can be something really little like I
don't exercise for a bit or I don't
hydrate properly for a few days or I
don't I don't get enough sleep I'm back
do you mean like I go dark let us go
dark in my head you know like you kind
of
the voice comes you know the voice comes
back but you know what I mean you start
getting down on yourself and you have to
be on top of all of those things like
what does the voice say
foreign
it will say you're not a very good dad
you're not a very good husband if I come
to do this podcast it will go why are
you bothering to do this you've got
nothing interesting to say do you mean
like you're gonna try and get away with
this at some point somebody's gonna tap
you on the shoulder and go we all know
if you leave quietly we won't say you
know that kind of thing you know I
remember like doing a run of like I was
particularly busy I had one of about six
panel shows like different Studio things
over two weeks and I was in a really bad
place and I turned up to each one of
them with the steadfast belief that I
was [__] at this right and I've got to
try and get away with it as much as I
was you know like I was just in a bad
place I turned up and I'd be sitting
there and like you know to be a comedian
you've got to be loose and like chilled
out and relaxed and it's almost like
being uh you know I've read a lot about
it about being in a flow State you know
being in the pocket whatever you want to
call it you can't be in the pocket if
you've got a voice in your head going
you're crap at this so it's like
yeah it just you just go through periods
of it I suppose the um when you went to
see that therapist in school why did you
go
so there was a very specific trigger
so what happened was is I had saved up
because I've always been really into
music and I'd saved up to get this like
Hi-Fi yeah
um like this really cool bit of stereo
equipment and I was too scared to take
it to UNI because I just thought
somebody's gonna neck this or it's going
to get smashed over so I left it at home
in my bedroom at home and my mum and dad
had a lodger
and he was sort of
he was somebody that come over from Sri
Lanka that they were kind of helping out
and
he'd been sleeping I'd been sharing a
room when I came back I shared a room
with him
and they'd moved that piece of stereo
equipment right because he needed to put
some stuff somewhere or whatever my
reaction
to something quiet nothing
was like it was like I really like was
like felt like
my mum and dad were trying to move me
out or they didn't care about my stuff
like and then I'd like really got pissed
off about it and then later on that
evening realized that that was a massive
overreaction and then recognized that I
wasn't in a good headspace you know like
I just felt like for me to have reacted
like that
probably was a sign that was because I
felt like I was going through some [__]
as well you know like you know you don't
feel right in yourself and then when I
reacted like that I thought
I need to I need to sort of speak to
somebody properly you know I'm not in a
good I'm not in a good place and so like
I think like two days later I looked
into it and then started going you know
what's um really has I think changed my
life is the amount of times I've had
this exact conversation with someone who
is maybe a comedian maybe not about the
voice in their head yeah and until I
started doing this podcast I had
absolutely no idea I couldn't comprehend
the thought that those people that have
a voice in their head that is somewhat
against them at times I can comprehend
it yeah and so for me like this isn't
the first time I've heard this this is
me maybe not even the tenth time it's
really eye-opening for me have you ever
and this is I mean this is almost an
impossible task because you're like
trying to piece things together in
hindsight but have you ever developed a
perspective or an opinion where that
voice comes from or why you have it and
someone else might not
um no I don't
I don't know is it you know like
why have I got it and other people
haven't I don't know it's something I've
thought about particularly I'm talking
to people that don't have it or don't
understand why I've got it
um
and I don't know I I don't know if it's
like
I mean I'm being super super pseudo
psychologist here but I sort of think
that you know when I said to you about I
sort of felt like everything was against
us yeah and you sort of go through this
period of like doing a formative years
of a lot of things going badly or going
negatively you then start to see that as
your default and then if something goes
right or something's going well then
that is against type or that is against
you know you're supposed to have [__]
happen to you you're like you're
bad stuff space that well you're
supposed to have bad experiences and so
then maybe that son and I'm just
freestyling here but maybe that kind of
gets hardwired into you so that even if
like you have positive things
um
you kind of
you you kind of don't accept them and I
also think of like sometimes I've
reflected on times when I was a kid like
really young
and done things I would consider be
selfish or I remember like this like I
have a vivid memory of being horrible to
my brother and the voice goes to me
that's you at your core like when you're
when you're being nice that is
conditioning but that is what you know
I've had that thought where that you
fundamentally is that person that that
nasty person but what you've done is
like social and conditioning has taught
you that you know you allow your brain
to go down those those thought Pathways
you know I sat with Gable Mata he's um
he's maybe he's like considered to be
like the leading
um psychologist therapist on
specifically childhood trauma and his he
was handed off during the Holocaust when
his because his mum was trying to save
him so she gave him to someone else and
he talks to me about how we interpret ex
we are narcissists as young children
here we think everything is about us so
parents are screaming that's because of
me yeah you know and and how children
are these like great like huge
narcissists so even though his mum was
doing an act of love he almost
internalized it as an act of Abandonment
which meant that he wasn't good enough
so he he talks about how he lived with
this kind of sense of not being good
enough the other conversation I reflect
on which Kent comes to mind as you're
talking is Steve Peters who wrote the
chimp Paradox and he talks about it
you've read it yeah great book he talks
about two periods he goes under the age
of like 10 you can develop goblins and
he refers to a goblin as something that
we can never really shake because of the
the neural Pathways in our brain a
pretty much changed for good and and we
can often not remember it because we
don't even start to form memories until
we're like three yeah or whatever and
those are your goblins and then he goes
after 10 it's really your Gremlins which
are things we can overcome yeah so it's
it's interesting that we can have these
sort of goblins but also not remember
where they came from and they can also
be just like narcissistic childlike
interpretation of events yeah yeah I
think I think I I do sort of agree with
that and I think like
one of the things I discovered is like
in in conflict and things like that you
know there was this uh
David Foster Wallace did this like
commencement speech
that I've read and it's about like this
thing that we're all hardwired to
believe that we are the center of the
universe right so like when you're going
to work and somebody cuts you up or
somebody takes ages in front of you at
the supermarket so why is this happening
to me and then as soon as you flip the
switch and go this isn't happening to me
I'm like this person's got their own
thing and this person's got their own
thing as soon as you do that your
ability to just chill out is miraculous
right and and I I do think that that is
part of it like you know the belief that
bad things happen to me what am I
talking about do you mean what are you
talking about do you think you're that
important that that they've got time for
Destiny to go nah Badger what are you
talking about you absolute God complex
having [__] you know that's the truth of
it you see what I mean it's just some
stuff happened man it's not Destiny
you're not on some route there's
nobody's got anything against you just
like what are you talking about who do
you think you are do you know what I
mean so is that is that you're kind of
like trying to combat that you said you
learned coping mechanisms yeah what are
those coping mechanisms
um
that sounds like one of them what you
just described there which sounded like
perspective yeah one of them is
perspective another one is just
is completely it's completely
surrendering yourself to the moment that
you're in so like
uh
if you complete
what I found is is like a lot of kind of
your so this Inner Voice or whatever or
a lot of your worries and stuff like
that are things that are not happening
to you at that time you know it's like
I'm worried this is going to happen I'm
worried I'm [__] at this and this is
going to happen
and one of the things I found is like to
just completely
be of this moment and this moment alone
and and sort of
yeah just just be present you know like
so if I come here
I could come here going
um if this podcast doesn't go well then
people are going to get in touch with
social media and then you know uh but
you know you can start getting yourself
in a thing you're not good enough to do
this podcast he shouldn't have
interviewed you have you seen the other
guests who's got this podcast why has he
done this
or if you just go I'm just going to come
here and enjoy this podcast and see you
know and I'm just going to be here in
the in the chat with you
you're just you're the way you
experience things completely changes do
you mean that you you just
you just become you just have a
different experience of the same thing
you can experience two things completely
differently like and the truth is all of
these things you're catastrophizing
are fine you know like if I go if I'm if
I'm crap on a panel show I don't get
booked for that panel show again so what
like who gives a [__] do you mean like
that's fine it's totally cool and then
the other thing is to just kind of
actively
be aware of when I'm getting like that
you know like sometimes you can't
necessarily stop it but I go I've gone
dark I mean you sort of go this is
happening but this is it's okay to feel
like this I don't need to block those
thoughts but they are irrational and I
just
I just know what's happening I mean I
need to get my nutrition in order I need
to get down the gym I need to get a good
night's sleep whatever I need to do to
sort myself out I need to do a bit of
like you know
headspace or whatever it is do you know
what I mean to try and get myself back
on an even kill whereas before before I
had those kind of coping mechanisms who
knew when I was going to come out of it
you know I just would submit myself to
it completely and then it would be like
chance that would come out of it you
know when you reflect on your journey
with mental health was there has there
what period of your life was the most
difficult
in terms of mental health yeah
um
I would say my late my late teens into
my kind of early 20s was really
challenging because
I I remember reacting I've got loads of
memories of reacting really badly to
things
um
like irrationally like over the top
reactions like
I remember like I didn't really do very
well in my a levels because I was just
like pissing about
and then when the a level results came I
just thought this at the end I can't
carry on with my life you know I really
like was like I can't
you know I was I was thinking about
taking my own life like regularly you
know like yeah there's loads of times
that you know there's loads of times
during that period
when I thought about it I did think
about it a lot
um
and I'd fantasize about it you know I'd
like think about how I was going to do
it I think about how easy it would be
after that I think about the
repercussions after I'm gone you know I
think if I could spend
time thinking about it you know so
um and that was kind of the toughest
time and then as I kind of got older
um
yeah it's sort of got
I still had the same issues but I
started to kind of be able to
to deal with them a bit more effectively
and and you know like I managed to shut
off The Voice you know there'll be
there'd be long times I don't have any
voice at all you know like it's just
gone
and then occasionally sort of go dark
again but yeah that was probably the
most challenging time you know there's a
there's a stereotype about Comedians and
them you know their perspective of
themselves not not being happy or
whatever there's that like long enduring
stereotype and I've sat here with Jimmy
Carr Etc and he's told me he actually
said to me he said you should ask you
should ask comedians not are they
depressed but like who in their family
was depressed which I thought that was
an interesting one what's your whole
observation as it relates to you on that
like stereotype that comedians are
either depressed themselves or their
family was or their mum was they had
someone in their home they were trying
to cheer up I don't I don't hmm I don't
know if I think that all comedians are
depressed I've said after a long
description
it feels like I've supplied a lot of
evidence to the contrary but I I don't
think all committees are depressed but I
do think that
I think that all comedians are wired
slightly differently certainly all the
really good ones I mean are the ones
that like some things happen they've had
something happen to them that has
changed the wiring that has made them an
outsider in some way and and it it might
be depression but it might be
you know it might be a change in
circumstances it might be a bereavement
it might be whatever it might be a class
shift it might be their parents you know
there's something about comedians that
just
they're just slightly different you know
their wiring is slightly different I do
genuinely believe that because I sort of
whenever I talk to comedians who I
really like after a while of talking to
them you go
I've spotted it
yeah there you go there it is exactly
they've all got that they've all got a
little bit of like you know I yeah
they've all got a little bit of faulty
wiring I think oh I don't mean faulty I
mean why different different yeah yeah
what is that in your words for you what
is that different wiring
that's made you like a like pulled
magnetized by the career of being a
stand-up com maker comedian
a writer I don't know I think that like
sort of I I think the speed in which
the speed in which everything changed uh
you know the the sort of my life
experiences as well as the fact that I
was sort of drawn to Comedy anyway
you know all of my family a lot my dad
was my family sort of all
pretty comedically you know that they're
all my co my my La the love language at
my house is taking the piss out of each
other I mean like you know my mum and
dad
um my brother and I just rinse each
other all the time that was that was
what I knew
that's what my kids are like that's what
we're like in my house you know and I
think that that's kind of contributes to
it but I think that
you know again I'm being sort of I'm
speaking from a position of deep
ignorance but like I think
having say in the normal trajectory for
my dad and the direction that they
wanted for me go so spectacularly wrong
has allowed me to accept taking a
different path do I mean like I I think
had that not happened I probably would
have gone I need to get like a regular
job like and follow this trajectory that
my parents want and I need to follow the
the the the Milestones of success that
everybody kind of attributes whereas
this thing allowed me to go well you
know what I'm just going to do the thing
I really want to do and let's see what
happens do you know what I mean and
initially that was you know before I was
in comedy that was teaching I didn't do
teaching because
I wanted to make well you don't do
teaching because you want to make money
but I wasn't doing teaching because I
wanted like respect from the community I
did it because I love the idea of
teaching children and then I ended up
moving into comedy and I just sort of
thought I actually kind of I kind of uh
have attached less
weight to financial remuneration to like
having the nice house to all of that
and I just want to do this I I just want
to be driven by
wanting to do this thing I mean because
if you chase the financial thing it can
still go horrifically wrong so why am I
doing that do you mean I might as well
Chase it that could still go wrong but
at least I'm doing something I enjoy
and that first you know I was reading
about your early sort of gigs in like
pubs and stuff like that yeah like eight
people or whatever that for that first
time a gig went well maybe it was it was
it Butlins your first that was my first
one I was like oh yeah yeah how did you
feel up on stage and the minute you
walked off stage when it went really
well well I can tell you a really
specific gig man that like it was quite
a bit into so I was you know you were
doing all these Pub gigs and I started
to get to a point where I was starting
to do well at these gigs right
and
I felt like okay I'm starting to get all
right at this you know for that level do
you know what I mean you certainly
couldn't have put me on at the Apollo at
that stage but like I was like I was
starting to feel like I was starting to
do well in these gigs
and what I hadn't done what I'd never
done is I'd never turned a room so what
I mean is Whenever However the gig was
going I would go on and follow suit
right so if it was a good gig I'd
probably have a good Gig if it was a
tough gig I'd still do all right but I'd
have a tough gig the first time I
absolutely bust my tits off is it was a
tough gig I was on second
and like the hosted struggle the first
actor struggled and then they got me on
and I started and they were quiet but by
the end of the gig it was like I was
like having a great one and that to turn
like that was the first time I'd ever
taken a room from being quiet to being a
great gig and I lost my mind I mean like
I was just like
the adrenaline was just insane man I
came off just like and you have to hide
that right because you know you don't
want to walk off just go yeah man yes
absolute smash time so I had to like
swallow that down and just go I've got
to leave quickly so I could scream in
the car
I felt if I felt in May that I remember
like as the gig was turning I didn't
want to dip out because as soon as you
go this is going well you're out at the
moment right so I had to like I had to
just like just keep doing the gig keep
doing the gig like had a great response
and I was like
oh my God that felt amazing it was
unbelievable man amazing
and has that kind of been your
relationship with stage where that's the
real like that's the
that's the Pinnacle in terms of like
feelings and emotions and like I guess
like self
I know affirmament
um
I don't know I mean like I definitely
enjoy the buzz of doing live stand up
more than anything else I do and like
nothing else really matched up to I
really do enjoy all the other stuff I do
but nothing can really compete with
standard I think it's partly because of
the possibility that you could really
die on your ass like that is exciting
that it could go horrifically wrong but
but this is something I was going to ask
is as someone who said that there's that
voice in your head and things can
trigger it what happens when it does go
horrifically wrong on stage it just
depends because like
the truth is your mindset changes right
because like
when I started doing stand-up
if I did badly it's probably because I
was [__] right whereas like now I I feel
like I'm all right at stand up
and now the gigs that go badly you need
those gigs you know like it's like going
to the gym you know if I'm trying to
write a new tour
I've got to write new material
so I go on with 10 minutes of new
material and I try it out if I if it
goes for nothing I'm disappointed
because none of the stuffs work but it
doesn't it doesn't make me think I'm a
[__] comedian I'm disappointed these
people are going to leave thinking
romish was crap tonight I can't do
anything about that but
you're sort of going this is part of the
process you know you're like I'm going
to the gym I've got to like you learn
more from those gigs do you know what I
mean and so
it's still don't get me wrong it's still
horrible it's horrible saying something
and then looking out
at that silence that never gets that
never gets easier man but
you sort of go that's what you've got to
do it's like when you're you've got to
take risks in the small rooms so that
when you do the big rooms it's better
you know like you know you want to do
stuff that's on there not necessarily on
the edge but you want to do stuff where
you might do an act out that you
wouldn't normally do or you might talk
about something you never talked about
before and the risk is you might tuck
into a big plate of [__] but when you're
in the big room when you're doing your
tour
you go I wish I'd taken more risks back
then do you mean so you can't it's kind
of a different it's kind of a different
process having said that I've done a
corporate gig where I've died I'm asking
for absolutely horrific you know like
you you it's oh God it's just so awful
man there's something really surprising
about someone who attests to having that
like tricky internal monologue with
themselves yeah that would then put
themselves in such a high risk position
I know you'd expect you'd think someone
would just stay at home and just avoid
any chance of reinforcing that negative
Voice by waking that prick up yeah yeah
it's it's amazing though the honest
truth is I would have that voice
regardless of what I did so I might as
well do something I really love should
it remain and I just absolutely like I'm
addicted to doing stand-up I'm addicted
to it even if I don't have a tour to
prepare for I'll go and do a gig you
know I can't not gig and it makes me
better at everything so if I'm doing a
travel show
I'm funnier on the travel show if I'm
regularly gigging if I'm not gigging
I'll be worse on that panel on that
travel shall be worse on a panel shot be
worse talking to you now like you know
you just you're just exercising that
muscle like being on stage I just feel
I'm addicted to it quick word from one
of our sponsors I've got a tip for all
of you that will make your virtual
meeting experiences I think 10 times
better
as some of you may know by now Blue
Jeans by Verizon offers seamless high
quality video conferencing but the
reason why I use blue jeans versus other
video conferencing tools is because of
immersion their tools make you feel more
connected to the employees or customers
you're trying to engage with and now
they're launching one of their biggest
feature enhancements to impact virtual
events so far called Blue Jean Studio I
actually used it the other day I did a
virtual event using the studio which I
think about 700 of you came to TV level
production quality all done by one
person with very little technical
experience on a laptop so if you've got
an event coming up and you're thinking
about doing it virtually check out blue
jean studio now let me know what you
think because I genuinely believe I know
this is an advert and I'm supposed to
say this but I genuinely believe it's
the best tool I've seen for doing really
immersive simple but high quality
production virtual events it is that
time of year again when my life becomes
incredibly reliant on Hill I'm busier
than ever I'm trying to be nutritionally
complete in all that I do I'm trying to
make sure I get all of the vitamins and
minerals that I need in my diet and heal
has been for the last three and a half
years the primary reason as it relates
to my diet that I've been able to be
nutritionally complete while also being
incredibly productive I always find that
when I'm most busy when I'm most sort of
sucked into my work my diet Falls by the
wayside that's the trend that I've seen
in all of my life especially when I'm
stressed that's when I I end up
resorting to foods that aren't
nutritionally complete or healthy for me
having fuel on hand has been a game
changer not just for me I see it in my
team we have two heel fridges in this
building that we record the podcast in
um and it's become a crutch I guess a
health crutch a positive Health crutch
for all of our team thank you huel for
creating a product that has helped me
and help my health stay intact in my
busiest days over the last couple of
years
to the episode so you went and became a
teacher yeah for a while
um and at some point you make the
decision to
reach out and
swing onto that next Branch I'm trying
to understand that that sort of pivotal
moment and like what happened what made
you take the leap crazy I mean I know
comedians when they start out don't get
paid no you run at a loss for a long
time and you were you had a kid on the
way in the process of you taking that
leap yeah logically it was foolish
there's no getting around that but um
well what happened was I started
teaching I was really loving it and then
I am
I just wanted to do stand up as a hobby
like all loads of teachers have got
Hobbies right you know so how many
teachers are in bands right so I just
thought this is going to be my thing I'm
going to do stand up
so I just started doing gigs and then
it started to go really well and then
somebody said to me
you know you could you could definitely
do this for a job what did you think
when they said that
I just it hadn't occurred to me well
that's a lie it had occurred to me but I
didn't think you don't
there's so many people trying to do
stand-up man like there's so many people
it's like
what are the chances that you're going
to be able to make a living out of it
it's like so slim and also I just hadn't
seen this a career thing but yeah
somebody comes and goes it was like it
was actually a competition I did a
competition called say thank you funny
in Edinburgh
and I was in I got to the semi-final and
it's like one person gets through to the
final and I made it through to the final
and then one of the judges came up and
said oh the reason that um we put you
through is because as soon as you walked
on we go this guy's gonna be a commit
like you just look like you're going to
be a comedian you can definitely do this
for a living
so there's just something about about
you just go this guy's going to be a
comic and so that's when I was like oh
okay and then my gigging them had a bit
more purpose and because before I just
thought I'm just going to try and get
good at this you know that but then now
I was thinking oh maybe I could do this
for a job
and then
um my agent and so so then I got an
agent and the agent said to me if you
really want to give this a go you're
going to have to leave teaching
and
so I talked to my wife about it and we
were like okay so I decided to leave at
Christmas
so you give it like a half terms notice
however
and
um
didn't you get caught by this night
this is so bad man but like
basically I was head of sixth form well
actually I was Junior had a sixth form
and um
I don't know why I had to make that that
clarification literally nobody cares so
it was running I'm pretty sure where
she's Junior
in that period of his life anyway why
did I make that correction anyway
um so I so basically I got asked to do
this like
this show at the Edinburgh Fringe like
every night it was just like compilation
mixed spill show whatever and it's like
a big opportunity
and um but I was supposed to be back for
a level a level results
so I just got in touch with him and I
said
um
my my wife's poorly and so I can't I
feel embarrassed I can't make it back
and they went okay and so I said I'll be
back as soon as I can and then I just
was like okay that's fine I've got away
with that and then I came back to school
the first day of September
and nobody in the office is talking to
me like it was like a proper Frosty
atmosphere and I thought oh God what's
happened there and then I opened my
computer and it said could you come to
HR
so I went to HR and they uh they said to
me
the lady said to me she's lovely
um she said to me so you couldn't come
back because uh your wife was poorly and
I said I said yeah as soon as that she
said that I thought this is over right
and then she goes right and then she
just opened this drawer I just pulled
out this folder and it had like reviews
me appearing on lineups like it was a
comprehensive dossier what I've been up
to at the Edinburgh Fringe Festival
and it was just so tricky because I just
thought that would be great to have
[Laughter]
that
um she was like what do you want to do
she goes you can't work with that team
anymore because I don't want to work
with you anymore because they're like
they feel so like they're so pissed off
with you for what you've done
she said we can move you to another head
of your team
and I sort of knew that I was going to
leave to do comedy at that stage so I
thought it's not fair to go and join
another head of your team I need to
leave so I just said I'll become a map
State like you know I'll take a step
down and be a math teacher and not have
any of that responsibility and so I just
did that for the remainder but
when I left the thing that kind of uh
uh
turn things upside down again was like
three days before I was due to leave
teaching my dad passed away suddenly of
a heart attack
and so
um
yeah it was and so then basically what
happened was is that the period after my
dad passing away
we had to stop at my mom's phone I
turned out my dad's finances were a
house of cards he got this Pub that he'd
been sort of
borrowing money from the house to
finance and all this it was like a
nightmare so it just meant that it was
like the start of my comedy crew was
pretty tough like we would just start
throwing our time into trying to figure
that out
how did you deal with that how did you
process the the loss of your father
it was really difficult because
um
I was really close to my I mean my
relationship as you can imagine was very
troubled with my dad because you know
I'd seen this guy
I'd seen this guy kind of want to leave
us and you know he'd been sleeping
around a lot
with a lot of different women and
[Music]
um I'd seen Mom you know when we're in
the bed and breakfast I'd seen my mom
cry herself to sleep every night and
like it was really hard you know that's
all because of my dad
so that was really difficult and I
remember like I'd had loads of arguments
with him he tried to be a parent again I
resisted because I felt like he didn't
want to be a parent how could you come
back in and start so you know it's very
difficult
but then as we got you know later on in
his life we got really close again and
you know I'm I'm absolutely just
delighted that when my dad passed away I
was I had a really good relationship
with him
but it was hard you know like my dad was
a person that I was most like in my
family my mom and my brother are very
similar and I was very and I'm very
similar to how my dad was
so I found it really really difficult I
found it really really hard and um
the thing that I feel really sad about
for him is that sort of when he passed
away he hadn't really got himself into a
comfortable position you know like
everything had gone wrong and he was
trying to work his way back up but
you know my recollection of my dad right
up to the day he died was like
absolutely working his ass off and kind
of chasing his tail you know so that was
that is a bit of sadness in that you
know I kind of think I wish he'd had it
a bit easier and it's like you know
sometimes I think you know I'll be
honest with you if my dad was still
around I would be broke because he would
have burned for all of my money that I'd
made from Comedy like my dad was like
such he's so irresponsible with mono so
um but yeah there's a bit of sadness
there
he could have gone back to Ramesh when
your father was alive in his last say
five years would you acted different in
any way I'm always so curious about this
because I'm in a position where I'm
fortunate enough that my parents are
still around and I I spend time often
forecasting the things I'm going to
regret is there anything where you think
I wish I'd said this or I should have
you know yeah I mean
so I I well no is the honest answer I I
think that you can
be in a position where you don't feel
that I mean look you're always going to
feel like I should have said I love you
more or whatever but I remember when I
was 18.
I'd come back from uni and I'd been out
like with some mates getting drunk and I
hadn't told my mum when I was going to
come back and I came back later than I
said I was gonna and I walked in pretty
inconsiderate and drunk and my mum and
dad are sat in front of the TV
and my dad said to me how can you come
back at this time and I said to him how
can you even talk to me about what I
should be doing in this house and then I
just launched into
a monologue about how he had no right to
tell me anything that I did in my life
how he wanted to walk away how can you
come back in here and tell me that I
should be doing whatever after what
you've done to Mom after what you've
done to me and me and my brother like
what are you doing like what you know
and I just went into this rant and he
sat there mate as I'm telling you now he
took it from me and like you know you
think about
you know Asian culture you don't talk
you know my dad was very laid back but
you don't talk to your parents like that
actually I mean but he sat there like he
took it he took every word from me
and
I stormed out the house
and my mum watched me have this
conversation and ordinarily like my mum
would have
uh picked me up on it but she didn't
and I never spoke to my dad about that
conversation again so like I went out
for a bit I came back in the next day we
never spoke about it my never my dad
never asked for an apology I never
apologized to my dad
if we never spoke about it again
and if my relationship with my father
hadn't have improved after this point it
would have I I don't know how I would
feel about that conversation I I it
would be something that and even now as
I'm saying it to you I made up with my
dad but it kills me that I said that to
him I don't disagree with anything I
said
but it does kill me that I said that to
him
but when it was his 60th birthday
my dad's got loads of brothers and a
sister that a load of them came over
from Canada and Australia and to see him
and I wrote in his card
thank you for being
a great dad and somebody I look up to
and my dad opened the card
and he said to me he like read the card
and he went really quiet it was like in
the middle of quite a raucous family
get-together and he opened the code up
really quiet and he just said to me do
you honestly mean that like he just
didn't believe that that was my view of
him and like he couldn't like and then I
realized up to that point my dad
had just thought we'd not you just
thought we weren't cool because of what
had happened in the past and he goes he
said to me do you honestly mean that I
said yeah of course I do
and then I felt you know I felt like
I feel like now my dad knew what I
thought about him do you know what I
mean and the what I think of my dad is
that he was a deeply deeply deeply
flawed human being that had a great a
lot of great things about him and and
you know
um
so yeah when he when he passed away I
felt really I I felt really close to him
but you know there's loads of things
like there's things where like if I'm
being honest with you when we started to
go where things started to go wrong I
was quite materialistic and you know can
I have this can I have that why can't I
have that anymore
what what are you doing you prick oh
yeah you know what I mean like why are
you valuing that stuff I remember like
I've got a really vivid memory of
wanting the new Public Enemy album right
it was like 8.99 on cassette or
something
and my dad said yeah I'll get it for you
and then on the day he just didn't have
a tenor we just he didn't have a tenor
no he'd have any money
and I like flipped out do I mean I
flipped out you promised me you get but
at that time you look at the context of
it you be forgiving if you've been
forgiving to that romesh everything's
going to tits up
this album is like some sort of security
wants to listen to that some sort of
normality I mean and it's a promise as
well exactly exactly and then he
couldn't in the circumstances what I
should have done was going okay cool I'd
love to get it that's what a good kid
does I'd like could you get it for me
when we can or I'll find another way to
get it but as a kid you sometimes
interpret that as Like You Don't Love Me
Maybe in a deeper you know what I mean
yeah 100 and it's something that I'm
really conscious of with my kids now
because
you sort of go I don't want them to get
the message that I don't love them so
but then you run the risk of like buying
them everything do you know what I mean
it's like it's such a difficult thing I
love you have it I love you have it
PlayStation yes I love you like hoodie
yes I love you trainers yes I love you
and then you go hold on a minute this
ain't good these kids need to hear no
so yeah it's a tricky one man what about
your mum she seems to have um been this
real Warrior throughout all of this
turmoil and I was reading some quotes I
know she did an interview where
um she just said that her the center of
her Universe was you two as brothers and
she would have done
anything to you including becoming a
cleaner and taking other jobs in shops
and stuff like that she seems to be a
kind of a real hero throughout your
story
yeah I mean
she's like she's amazing you know you
think about
um
you know she came over from Sri Lanka
my she was you know 19 20 when she came
over she grew up in a Tiny Village
she come gets thrown into this new
country she tries to make her way make
new friends her husband is immersed in
the world in the country much more than
she is because she's a stay-at-home you
know wife or mother
and she's like you know making her way
and then
her life gets thrown upside down
and she goes to a position where she has
to single-handedly raise her two sons
because her husband's kind of dipped out
and
and on top of that she's got to deal
with the Heartbreak of what her husband
has done
as well as go what I've got to like I've
got to brush my shoulders off and like
and start and support these kids
it's like amazing it's amazing you know
it's amazing and so like you know she
she's like a hero of mine for for how
she's been for all of that time and how
she needs to be now I mean don't get me
wrong she loves spending money and she
loves being recognized and she loves a
celebrity like being a celebrity she
loves being on TV all of that
but I love I'm delighted I'm delighted
that my mum's period of life now after
what she went through is being on TV
being comfortable having a house paid
off drives a nice like great Wicked like
do you mean like
this is amazing do you know what I mean
that this is amazing I mean don't get me
wrong I do sometimes have a go and go
you don't need that much I mean like you
like chill out yeah and like you know
she does things that annoy me like for
example she crashed her car she wasn't
happy with the courtesy car that we're
offering so she then said to me uh Rami
you need to give a guy that works at the
insurance company two tickets to your
toe because he upgraded my car
so she does stuff like that
and like so but but mate she's like what
I mean she's incredible you know I can't
you know you can't say I can't say no to
her I mean like she doesn't well there's
a you know it's debatable whether she
takes a piece or not but like my mum's
amazing she's amazing and like
yeah I I I I owe a lot to her you know
so she is she is a hero of mine
definitely does she know that does she
have you ever said to her what what you
think and feel about that period and how
she behaved I have said that to her what
I would say is that sits in direct
contradiction to how many times I phone
her do you mean like like I I tell her I
love her
but I don't get in touch enough for as
much as she'd like I don't see her as
much as she'd like so
um
yeah I probably should sort that out I
mean that I should probably sort that
out but um but she knows she knows what
I think of it yeah definitely I've got
no doubts in my mind that she knows what
I think of it when did you make it
and what was the The Catalyst moment you
know making it is kind of like a there's
so much assumption in it that there was
a moment where everything changes that's
why it's a bit of a shitty question if I
reflect on that but like when was what
was the the first stone that fell or the
first Domino that fell that created the
cascading event I hear about this figure
in your life called Sean Walsh yeah and
the impact he had in believing in you
and being very patient with you yeah I
love that because we can all think of
that that I can think in my life of that
person that like bizarrely had faith in
me yeah a little bit more than I did
myself yeah yeah well
it's an interesting one with Sean
because
basically what happens he saw me at a
gig in Brighton and
like he liked liked the set or whatever
and then he was going on tour
and I was like
so at that stage if he was tour support
who basically he asked me to support him
on tour with your tour support you drive
you drive the ACT you drive the main act
so I'd go and pick him up and
and at that stage I was so broke that um
you know sometimes I feel I don't know
you get paid after the gig like you know
after you've done a run a gig sometimes
it's like I don't know if I don't know
if I've got enough money for petrol to
like go and get him it's like it was
like proper like I was like really
running it on fumes financially
and um
So speaking of taking two gigs
and like that money from those gigs was
basically keeping our bills paid you
know if I didn't have those gigs I don't
know what we would have done and then
during that time
um
I one of the things that he offered
today that I never took him up on was I
couldn't pay the road tax on my car
and had some money due to coming from a
gig and I said to Lisa when this money
comes in I'll pay the road tax your wife
my wife sorry yeah I said I said to her
when when this money comes in I pay for
the road tax anyway we came home from
the shops and the car was gone
and they'd impounded it for not having
road attacks and I phoned up and I said
um
how do I get my car back and they said
well it's a 450 pound fine and it's 150
pounds for every day that we have the
car for
so I said enjoy the car and then put the
phone down
and I said to Lisa I'm really sorry we
don't have a car anymore I don't know
what to say I can't afford like there's
no way every day I spend trying to get
that 450 quid we've got to pay another
150 this is like mad
and then I told Sean about it and he
straight away goes I'll give you the
money to get a car because I'll just
lend it to you because I know you're
good for it because I know you'll start
making money from coming and you'll be
able to pay me back and I never took him
up on it
but saying that
was huge like it was so huge
um
anyway
when we were on tour he started doing
the show called stand up for the week
and that was like they did topical
material and you had writers working on
it he said to me
can you write me some like write some
stuff for the show like and it actually
what you start doing is you started
going what do you think about this story
and I'll tell him like he goes you know
what comedy angles have you got in this
story and I talked to him and he'd like
okay okay and little did I know he was
trying to help me out right so he was
trying to test the waters so go see your
angles on this
then you guys can you send me some stuff
like send me some stuff you've written
and I was sending stuff and you guys
this is all [__] I can't this is
unusable
and you guys try again next week I'll
send you the stories have a go and then
I did it again and he goes some of this
is good most of it is [__] and then I
did that and for a cut another couple
times he goes right do you want to come
into the writer's room because I get
into the writer's room and and you can
sit in and like do some stuff
so I sat in and then I became a writer
on stand up for the week I started
becoming a writer and sign up for the
week
and then he did a show
called Shaw Morse world
and he got me in as a writer on that and
then they did a press launch
for the show and they were doing a
comedy gig as part of the press launch
and Sean got me on that comedy gig
and I did the gig and the guys that
produced live at the Apollo
were there for that gig because it was
like the same sort of production house
that do the show they I had a great set
and two days later they phoned me and
asked me to be alive at the Apollo
and like at that time
the money that you get for doing live at
the Apollo basically would pay my bills
for six months right and so I didn't
have an agent at the time so they had to
phone me directly with dropping the kids
off at nursery and I got got the phone
calls like Ramesh this is the guys from
live at the Apollo just wondering if you
wanted to be on the next series and I
just want to hold on a sec
yeah yeah I think I can do that and
straight away I go I can do comedy for
another few months yeah I mean I can I I
can pay bills for the next few months I
don't know it might come to the end of
that few months and I'm still not not
got anywhere but I've just bought I've
just I've got six months in this game
still it was like
it was incredible and that is down like
you know Sean got me that man I mean
like he
he was like giving me work that was Pat
you know I'll never forget that
then you did live at the Apollo yes how
did that feel
it was unbelievable man it's like it was
such an iconic show
um
I heard your your dad always used to say
to you when you were younger about you
doing live at the Apollo so when I
started gigging
I was trying to get stage time and it's
quite difficult you know it's quite
difficult to get gigs like there was a
good Open Mic circuit was quite
difficult to get gigs my dad was running
a pub at the time
and he said to me just run a gig here
and like you can host the gig and like
your book people book your mates or
whatever he goes with dirt like and I go
okay so I start running a gig there and
we're like when I did my first gig there
it'll go to me I don't understand why
you're not alive at the Apollo I said
Dad I've got like four minutes of gear
like and it's not great it's not as easy
I said if it's that easy to get along
with your Polo everyone would be doing
it you know what I mean but he used he
was he kind of veered between being
quite harsh and being like he he always
thought I was going to make it like he
was he had no doubts he was like you are
going to make it as a comedian but then
he would come and see me at gigs and
he'd go the first guy was a lot better
than you tonight
like you go you need to think about that
because like you were like you guys you
did fine don't get me wrong but that
first card was great like that's who
everyone's gonna remember after this gig
and he goes to think about so he was
like he would give me like honest and
heartfelt criticism but within the remit
of within the context of the fact that
you are going to make it but I'm just
telling you tonight you weren't good
enough do you know what I mean so it was
a bit of sweet when you did live at the
Apollo for that reason that he he wasn't
there at that time because a little bit
I mean the whole thing man it's like my
dad never saw me really
I mean I started doing the Circ I mean
like he didn't my dad died before I
became a full-time comedian you know so
he's not seen any of it he saw like me
doing these shitty gigs and he used to
come to all those gigs and he started to
see me do some circuit gigs which were
like you know they were like you felt
like you'd made it you know you're
playing a 400 seater room on a Saturday
night whatever feels great you're like
you feel like I'm in show business or
whatever
but you never really saw any of that he
never saw me do any TV I know he did see
me do one terrible bit of TV I did
soccer am
um that was like my one thing that he
saw me do
and it went terribly so he's only ever
said he said he obviously we have a
terrible time on TV so yeah it is a bit
of sweet to be honest yeah you'll run
from that point of live at the Apollo to
where you are now incredible
as a comedian I mean there's very few
people that get to sit at that top table
as you said as you identified when
you're a teacher but to be one of those
sort of standout comedians that
everybody knows is really really
incredible now when I reflect on do you
take that do you take your body language
is quite telling you were uncomfortable
and awkward yeah yeah
um I I just feel like um
I feel really lucky
I just feel like so much of that is
outside of your control do you mean like
that's why I feel like I feel a bit like
um I don't want to ex there's part of me
that doesn't want to accept that do you
mean like accept that comment that you
make you sort of go
there's so much luck to this you know I
think comedies and meritocracy up to a
point
but then you just get lucky and you know
so I I do feel really lucky but and
don't get wrong I'm very grateful but do
you work hard now and you're in your
estimation well I work a lot I mean
there's no doubt about that whether I
work hard or not is another question I
mean I just like
everything I do is like fun I know
that's such a wanky thing to say but
like I love doing stand up I love doing
panel shows I love doing travel show
like she doesn't ever feel like I'm
working hard the only struggle I would
say is that I'm away a lot do you mean I
like
I I'm kind of saying to my family I'll
see you in a week like
you know that bit I've had to I've
actually had to take I've had to sort of
take action on really so sometimes like
when you're doing a lot of travel shows
it's not really fair you know to be away
as much as I have been in the past but I
don't feel like I work hard like I
really love what I do like I love what I
do so much and I know that's like a
really privileged position to be in and
sometimes I'm going to be honest if I'm
working on a script
at three in the morning because I've got
like I've got to make a deadline I do
think oh God this is [__] I am
working hard now I mean but it's still
fun I'm still writing a script about
some guy I'm still writing a script
being trying to be funny you know that's
what all of my day is when you've come
from where you come from and you believe
that you're lucky is there not this kind
of overarching or this driving force
that's like [__] you can lose this at
any minute 100 I mean you think about it
like
uh my my dad was going all right and
then it all went wrong and then I was a
teacher I took a gamble on Comedy and
then we were broke so I've had two
examples of like
of it going like you know everything
going
so definitely there is part of me I
don't consciously think that
there is definitely part of me I you
know when you think about how much
how much you're willing to hustle I
think part of that comes from
feeling insecure yeah a little bit I do
think so I do think so but now what I
would say to you sitting here now if it
all went if I stop being on TV now or
like the phone stopped ringing or
whatever I'll be cool it's fine I mean I
just I just don't
I'm just not worried about that anymore
you know like you I will always do stand
up and if TV stops and all that'll stop
all that kind of stuff stops
I feel kind of comfortable I'm I'm all
right you know it's it'll be fine you'll
see me down the park and you go that guy
looks like that guy that used to host
Lego
are you are you I hate I hate this this
word but I'm going to ask the question
anyway are you happy
I know that I've talked a lot about my
inner voice and all of that and how I've
struggled with that
but I am happy yeah I I do I do consider
myself to be happy I I think like
I've got a great
I've got a great situation you know I've
got a beautiful family I'm happy with
being able to
um
to do nice things I'm sort of
my my mum's in a good position my
brother's in a good position
I love my job you know all of those
things I do I do feel happy do I have
dark moments where I descend into into
like troubled times yeah 100 but that's
not happiness isn't buzzing off your
tits the whole time I mean what is it
I think it's like going I'm in a state
of I mean generally speaking it's like
you know it's like the stock exchange
you know you're going to have ups and
downs but generally speaking you're on a
decent you're on a decent trajectory and
I feel like I am you know if one of your
um one of your boys Alex Charlie Theo
comes to you and says Dad right I'm
going out into the world based on your
ex your lived experience what is what
wisdom
do I need to know Dad to to make it in
life to be happy and to get to where I
want to go what are the things that
spring to mind that you would impart on
those boys
well you know you asked me about me
being lazy and and I still believe I am
lazy and the way that I have managed to
Life Hack That is to
do things that I really do enjoy so
I think for them
choose something that you really feel
passionate about that you really love
and don't for me personally don't think
about this external this goal down the
line that you're trying to get to do
this thing brilliantly do you mean do
eat like every single thing you come to
do do that to the best of your ability
so when I do a gig it doesn't help me to
think about what this gig could lead to
I just need to be great at this I just
need to do the best I possibly can at
this gig I'm not in control of anything
that happens after that so every single
step of the way you try and do that the
best that you possibly can if you do
that if you love what you do and you do
that honestly you you're on a good path
they have a relationship to only those
two points in the sense that when you
love it you can become a master because
you do it for fun yeah hard like things
that feel like [__] stuff like things
you don't enjoy it's hard to master yeah
but also the other thing is even if you
do enjoy something like if I do a panel
show
and I and I'm thinking about what the
potential career path of that if I do
well on this panel show then somebody
will see me on this and then I'll get
booked for that and then if I start
getting booked for that maybe somebody
offered my own if you sit in a studio
with that in your head God help you I
mean all you've got to do I'm not in
control of that I don't that's so
outside of I can't do anything about
that what I can do something about is
being as good as I possibly can in this
immediate circumstance that's all I can
do and then everyone else takes care of
itself which I mean and it might happen
it might not but why am I thinking about
that all that'll do is tighten me up
when I'm here I need to be like I need
to be in the moment I need to just be
loose and having a good time and then
not worry about that it reminds me so
much of what so David brownsford said to
me about the British cycling team he
said one of the first things he did when
he came into that failing cycling team
was get them to stop thinking about the
podium right right yeah because of all
the emotional impact that has when
you're racing when you're thinking about
the medals yeah and even when you're
you're in training thinking about the
podium is is not conducive with being
productive and focused his whole thing
was like can we find a way to be one
percent better today yeah yeah that's
controllable when people when fight when
they find that game they have that sense
of momentum and it's exactly what you've
described there I like focus on the
controllables and not the fear that's
induced by the anxiety of like oh what
happens if next that you know which 100
man which is which kind of which goes
against the self-development community
who are all like five-year Planet you
know like yeah I know I know I did I did
think to myself do I need to do that
but I have no plan I I like you know I I
don't know I just think like
it's like you know when people go and
lots of people I know that are really
successful do this where they go I want
to get a bafta by whenever right
to my mind I just think there is there's
so many variables outside of your
control to getting a bath like why would
you give yourself a Target that's so
outside of your like so many things that
could happen that nothing to do with
your ability or anything to get you a
bathtub it's like there's a jewelry
something that you might not like you
know look there's so many uncontrolled
why would you do that to yourself do you
know I mean it's like what I can go is I
want this show to be really good I want
this show to make me laugh I want to
make something I'm proud of I can do
that do you mean like that's that's
inside the Realms of possibility
seems like a much happier psychological
world to live in to be to live in the
controllables than to be like because
then we don't get the bafta the unmet
expectation of that person on the jury
that didn't like you yeah it's like
you're right it's like unnecessary
torture yeah
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guests asks a
question for the next guest not knowing
who they're asking it for and the
question that's been left for you is how
will we make progress
in solving the crisis of
meaning today I've got an absolute
Stitcher are you joking that's literally
what I said
hahaha
should I should I I'll give you
something yeah
oh my God we're having such a nice time
oh my God yeah
um basically the guy was talking about
how life expectancy for the last two
years has begun to drop and what he
pointed out was that it's it's to do
with a sort of a a broader
epidemic of meaninglessness in people's
lives where they're turning to opioids
suicide and those are the things that
contributing to this crisis of meaning
so he's saying how will we make progress
and solve this crisis of meaning where
people's lives don't feel meaningful
um enough so they're turning to opioids
they're becoming depressed they're you
know
Dying by Suicide
he's saying how do we go about solving
that today
well
I don't know but what I would say is one
of the things that I noticed during the
the pandemic was like when people's jobs
were taken away or they couldn't do
their jobs and
people weren't able to socialize
people's identities completely
disappeared like they just didn't know
what they were like you know you go if
I'd not go into my job
and I'm not seeing people I'm not doing
things what the what the hell is this do
you mean and I think that
if people that had other stuff that they
could do I mean creatives were able to
like do stuff and find some purpose and
do stuff not necessarily for people's
consumption but just to sort of to sort
of scratch that itch
I think if you can get people to to
allow themselves to kind of engage with
things that are outside of this kind of
I'm doing this for this and I'm doing
this if you can get people to
to engage in things that are for their
own kind of enrichment outside of fine
you know outside of a job and outside of
all this then I think you that's a way
of equipping people sort of more
effectively to to find that I guess
would be
a freestyle answer to this
no I completely agree we've talked a lot
about that a lot how the Arts and um
realizing that we can all be artists
it's not just a job title um even if
you're a lawyer you can pursue that the
teachers pursuing those bands they're in
um and I can I reflect on the huge
impact it's had on me becoming learning
to DJ in the middle of the pandemic like
I did really yeah how are you getting on
you know
I'm not I'm not I'm not going to sell
out any festivals just yet I did my
first gig the other day I'm [__] but I'm
at like the I'm at the the top end of
[__] yeah got you so
I I do a hip-hop show on radio no well I
I have a show yeah no but I don't I
don't DJ on the show I just talk and
some like you know I just plug you know
I don't mix on it okay so they gave me a
challenge I'm just giving I'm just
telling you this so I was learning to DJ
they said they knew I wasn't into DJ so
they gave me this piece of paper on the
show saying Ramesh by the end of this
series we wanted to do a 20 minute mix
for the show right and then as we were
talking about they're going to be great
and then you can do like regular mixes
anyway I went off and did the 20 minute
mix I submitted the mix they played it
I've not been asked to do another one
that that that that perceived start of a
series of ramish mixes has evaporated
after they had that first if you don't
ask for feedback no I don't want
feedback if they if they if they don't
ask you for another one I don't need
that feedback I know what the feedback
is practice
thank you so much for your time today
um huge honor to speak to you and your
story is because of the way I can relate
to it has been incredibly inspiring and
I appreciate your honesty I'm I like I
said when you were talking about the
voice in your head I literally my whole
body had these Goosebumps and I felt
this huge wave of sadness because
I don't think people realize and people
that have the privilege of having a a
positive voice in their head I don't
understand yeah you know I don't
understand that the idea that my my head
can turn against me right we need to
have that conversation more because it
helps us to unders like have empathy
yeah yeah you know so thank you so much
no thanks for having me man
um I was really enjoying it up until
that last question well you can stitch
someone up now let's do this thank you
man
[Music]
as some of you will know Intel I've been
sponsoring this podcast for a little
while now and this makes the search for
high spec laptops super easy because all
you have to do is look for the Intel Evo
badge and you'll have everything you
need the thing that's great about the
Intel Evo platform is that you still
have so much choice and that's key for
me there are now over a hundred designs
that have been Intel Evo certified so
you can quite literally find the perfect
laptop for you amongst that vast
selection now I've got two in front of
me here one is the Samsung Galaxy book
360 which rotates over 360 degrees and
is amazing for things like team
presentations meetings Etc also really
great for keeping podcast notes on when
you're sat with a guest but I personally
use the Dell XPS because it's
lightweight super lightweight and its
battery lasts for over nine hours even
while you have multiple tabs open which
helps to to stay at the pace that I run
out in my day-to-day life so to find out
more and get your hands on your own
intelivo laptop head over to intel.co.uk
Evo right now let me know how you get on
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
crafted are a jewelry brand and they
make really meaningful pieces of jewelry
the really wonderful thing about crafted
jewelry is it's super affordable it
looks amazing the pieces hold tremendous
meaning and they are really well made I
think I've worn this piece for almost a
year it hasn't broken hasn't changed
color because it's really really good
quality and it costs roughly 50 Quid
people will be surprised when they hear
that they'd probably assume that all of
my jewelry is like solid gold and cost
thousands and thousands of pounds but
what's the point when you can achieve
the exact same effect from a piece of
jewelry that's high quality and costs 50
Quid that's why I buy crafted
[Music]
foreign